there's nine thousand
different forms of pfas
in our environment nine thousand just as
a context almost everyone has it in
their blood let's become aware of this
stuff
so that we can make another choice
we all know that avoiding highly
processed food is a powerful step to
eliminating toxins from your diet but
what about the chemicals that we put on
our bodies or absorb into our skin from
our household products or even our
clothes today's guest Darren Olean who
you may know from his many past
appearances on the show or perhaps from
his star turn as Zac Efron's co-host on
the hit Netflix series down to earth has
a name for the pernicious ways in which
the many products we assume are safe are
actually harming Us in very real but
often invisible ways and that term is
fatal conveniences I'm talking about
everything from deodorant and denim to
detergent and even dental floss actually
abound with chemicals so today we
attempt to make sense of this Insanity
how to know what products are safe to
use and what we should avoid you're in
very good hands because Darren when he
isn't traipsing the Far Corners of the
globe or working on new Sustainable
Solutions for agriculture energy and
industry has spent the better part of
his entire life studying this very topic
all of which he condenses and shares in
his fantastic new book fatal
conveniences the toxic products and
harmful habits that are making you sick
and the simple changes that will save
your health I think this just might be
the most powerful and impactful of our
five public conversations to date so get
ready to take notes hit that subscribe
button and be prepared to be educated to
be nourished and most importantly be
empowered before we dive in this episode
is brought to you by Roka now I get
asked fairly consistently about the
glasses that you see me wearing on the
show well the answer is Roca these are
specifically the Hamilton frames I love
them all the frames that Roca makes are
high performance super light amazing
Optics they've got tons of great Styles
they never ever slip off my face and
I'll be sharing a bit more about Roka
later but for now enough Let's uh let's
do the thing
well good to see you thank you uh for
coming back I was thinking about
um the many times that you've appeared
on this podcast you've always been such
a popular guest this is your fifth
appearance so I think we've logged
somewhere between 8 or 10 hours of
conversations amazing going all the way
back to our first episode was was 153
that was way back wow yeah how many are
you at now so worse in this mid seven
seven wow 40 something I don't know 750.
that was in this back room
you know just like in this little
engine engineering room or something I
can't remember where the first one was
that we did was it at my house or no no
it was at uh your partner's business oh
yeah I mean we've had a few locations
but we got our HQ here you've been here
many times but not not a guest on the
podcast so welcome thank you man yeah
man we've covered so many things over
those episodes we've talked about
superfoods of course plant-based
nutrition we went deep on water and
hydration we talked about verucas and
all the work that you've done in the
rainforest and the the uh various you
know regions across South America and
all your travels we've talked about
breath brain States we talked about down
to earth I think uh the last time you
were on which was mid pandemic right so
lots happen since uh since the last time
man another season of down to earth
um and now you've got this new book
fatal conveniences so congratulations
buddy thanks dude yeah we know I know
two and a half years of dude I know how
long and how hard you've been working on
this thing like an albatross you know
around your neck uh a lot went into it
um I loved it
and I think it's really going to help a
lot of people it's really powerful my
experience in reading the book
was weirdly this strange combination of
it both being on the one hand like a
very Breezy easy read like it's very
easy to kind of like go through it and
at the same time this extremely dense
you know comprehensive almost uh you
know research paper where you basically
canvas every single thing that's out in
the world trying to kill us and the main
takeaway is kind of
you know God damn it's hard to be a
conscious human in the modern world
isn't it it's [__] inconvenient it's
very you know yeah yeah you know it's
this one this this shocked me a bit
I naively
said I'm going to write this book
because I you know
in parallel to 30 years of kind of the
the start of understanding this with my
dad which we can unpack and talk about a
little bit but
this has been a part of my life ever
since then so I'm like yeah no problem
I know a bunch of this stuff let's write
a book I'll be able to crank it out in
six months I literally thought that that
was the first kind of idea and then two
and a half years later yeah because it's
like when you really it's like as
anything Rich right when you
when you really look
and really ask questions and really
start to study something
mostly it's it's it's more complex than
you can possibly imagine anything in
life all environmental issues all of
these chemicals why they're there why
they're not there whatever it is it's
always very complex and so
that's why flippantly in this world when
you're seeing people just making
comments
and this kind of click baitable stuff
it's it's it it doesn't do a lot of
service to the complexity of things and
you know our mutual friend Paul Hawkins
is such a great example of of inviting
the powers that be into the conversation
and into proactivity of how to make
changes and and and even you know on on
down to earth when we sat sat down with
the professor who wrote black emu
try losing track of his name right now
um
that you know you know we go into all
these complex issues and he says you
know we say what do we do
and he literally says
have tea and talk about it with
each other so that we come together so
so it's like so that being said
every chapter in that book is is is is
so complex
and so big that easily could have been a
book yeah of course I mean that's a
really powerful perspective that you
know as you mentioned is applicable
across the board to whatever subject
matter you're trying to understand we go
into these things thinking we have an
idea of what it is oh it's a black and
white it's US versus them we see a lot
of that on the internet the algorithm
favors uh the US versus them model and
amplifies that and a lot of you know
so-called you know quote-unquote experts
you know spewing here and there uh in a
way that that uh makes it sound like
they know what they're talking about but
not necessarily you know uh is that a
good Arbiter of of true wisdom and
Mastery as you know is the capacity to
really immerse yourself in a subject
matter where you go on that Journey
where you think you know and then the
more you know the more you realize you
don't know and then ultimately through
lifelong dedication you come out the
other side and have some level of of
wisdom matched with humility and you're
able to communicate it in simplistic
terms and I think a lot of people
particularly on the internet
um are our Pretenders to that level of
Mastery and they hide behind a lot of
language and a lot of
phraseology that that that makes
that that makes people think that they
know what they're talking about but real
Mastery is being able to condense it
down and explain things simply with that
level of humility and I feel like on
some level I don't you know like not to
you know overly project here I don't
know that you would consider yourself a
master on any of the subjects that you
know these rabbit holes that you went
down but you were able to communicate
really complex stuff and and like I said
you know a very readable way and each
one of these chapters is you know a
launching pad or you know starting gate
for somebody to you know go deeper into
their own exploration yeah I think you
what you said I agree a thousand percent
and that book is a definitely an example
of knocking me back a notch thinking I
know and and sitting me in the seat of
like
this is
number one so shocking I don't know how
many times Rich going through each
chapter in each research I was like what
the [__] is going on like I don't I'm
reading it and I still don't understand
why this is happening right so that
coupled with just the enormous amount of
research that was used and cited and
helped guide
you I'm going oh my God I'm a forever
student
forever student of this modern day
conundrum that we're in because we all
were born into it
all of us right and and and we weren't
even given our first breath and we were
already inoculated with chemicals in the
umbilical cord that shows up many
different studies many different ways
and that's the shocking thing and did
you have a choice did that little baby
in the womb have a choice in utero no so
you know all of this stuff yeah man it
knocked me back I wanted to quit
um my my
researchers you know going back to the
table this isn't working this isn't
working
and then you realize wow I am so naive
to all of this stuff and
um that this literally takes a village
and a team and professionals to to amass
this knowledge and to try to put it and
now to answer one of those things about
trying to make it
palatable and digestible for someone
technique that I constantly use shout
out to my brother Troy
he doesn't know this
but I constantly listen through his
perception of the world so it was sort
of written with him in my like he was
the audience member that you're writing
for because if he doesn't my brother's
like if he learns something and he can
understand it
it's not all people are like this but he
goes
oh well why would I do that why would I
drink out of this
microplastic induced estrogen mimicking
phthalate filled plastic water bottle
when I can just go
all right I got tested well water and
I'll use a glass
why would you why would you drink out of
plastic now knowing what it is so with
that you know I I don't mean this
disparagingly but just a simple Common
Sense filter of of looking at the world
I wanted to make the book with infinite
complexity
make it so that my brother my mom
Midwestern roots of family and people
and friends could could read this book
and go okay I get it yeah yeah yeah well
I think you I think you succeed on that
front
um
you know on the one level uh you know
you can read this book and and basically
the thesis is it's like everything we
use by eat where everything we sleep on
everything we use to keep cool or clean
ourselves or our stuff is is bad and is
trying to kill us right it's like kind
of you know dispiriting and and dystopic
in in many ways and it's easy to
obviously be overwhelmed by that and and
uh and and you know you know perhaps
freaked out it's a matrix-like
experience as you kind of describe in
the book but it's paired with
Solutions and and optimistic you know
kind of tonality to it
um
in that it provides all of us with
um a kind of call to action to reclaim
our sovereignty and I know sovereignty
is a big that's big with you to you know
really recognize our own agency and and
shoulder the responsibility that we all
have to make better choices for
ourselves and on some level that's
empowering and those choices you know
one single Choice by one single person
isn't going to change the world but you
know in macro you scale that up and the
more consumers are conscious of those
choices the more our capitalist Society
responds to meet that demand totally and
that's the inclusive like you know you
bring people into the conversation I
mean that's really the macro thing here
it's like we can point fingers and say
these people are bad or evil this
product should be banned Etc But
ultimately change is forged through
um you know mature conversations with
you know people in the seats of power
who can you know change the course of
how we do these things right and if you
alienate them and don't create a
welcoming environment to have that
conversation to begin with you're never
going to get off the dime yeah yeah and
that's the
you know on the one hand you know you
and I have been in the health space for
a long time you know I wrote super life
super stoked to write that as my first
book and kind of get this foundational
principle out and then then it finally
dawned on me you know and Harper came
back like hey man like we can write
another book what would you and I'm just
going just like blaringly obvious was
this invisible
hard to pin down
world
of chemicals and emfs and toxicology
that is pervasive pervasive everywhere
that is hitting us on so many different
angles hundreds of interactions of of
lab created chemicals every day all day
um that
literally disrupting our endocrinesis
system disrupting and lowering
testosterones thyroids pituitary you
name it and it just keeps going so I'm
like okay well
I'm writing something on the one hand of
super life trying to help people get
better but then this invisible elephant
right in the room of our world is just
screaming in my head
and
the full circle because my dad was the
first
teacher
you know as a teacher he then taught me
hey man
in order for me to be around you and I
was studying College I was soaking up
physiology at the time but I still
thought my dad was weird
but my dad was the first one
telling me and through his discovery of
he was chemically sensitive
right and and then I'm like that's crazy
right maybe he's you know he was the
angry dry drunk most of my life and now
some something else is happening
but then when he'd say hey man he'd send
that care package to me in college
you're coming home this weekend well you
got to do laundry with this unscented
brand this bar soap this shampoo this
conditioner and don't wear these kind of
clothes
when I actually then did it because in
order to hang out with him and see him I
had to abide by these things
I then started to realize how
desensitized I was
um from all of these things and I
started to feel better even though I
didn't know I was not feeling all that
optimal
and then you know so that was the that
was the start and my dad's mystery
became him being the first person to
start and not the first person in his
area and maybe southern California to
really start to investigate this through
multiple doctors that were trying to
figure out why his he had neurological
decline he had depression uh he he
literally could not he was his his
endocrine system was being hijacked his
nervous system was being hijacked his
stress response was being hijacked so
finally he was able to get to like oh
well there's the Azo dies coming off of
my favorite Harley t-shirts uh you know
my blue jeans my paints my fire
retardants my uh you know any smells
perfume parfum all of this stuff yeah
all that cologne you were wearing back
in the day right
freshman year in college right sure
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
[Music]
yeah I mean the thing that's so
interesting about this you know and I I
I've heard you share about your dad many
times but I learned I learned a lot more
about that backstory that I didn't know
and you know for those that are
listening or watching it's easy to think
well Darren kind of jumped on this fatal
convenience's idea when he started doing
segments on his podcast talking about
this those got popular you started
making reels on Instagram little videos
like little nuggets on this this concept
but it really does go all the way back
to your childhood and this condition
that your dad suffered from at a time
where you know Not only was that weird
like I can imagine you know how other
people responded to that you talk a
little bit about it in the book like
like people didn't know what it was what
it was or what caused it or or the fact
that you would have to you know jump
through all these hoops just to be in
his presence must have been you know
very foreign and and perhaps off-putting
to a lot of people it was really hard
for him I mean here's the you know the
the male figure in my life who's kind of
being you can't see what's going you
can't see what the abuse that's
happening inside so he's just nuts right
he's you know he he must be crazy he was
a veteran you know you and then you tell
on top of the whole thing I didn't know
the whole story of the keepers of the
dragon and his experience on on this
aircraft carrier uh during the the Cuban
Missile Crisis which is wild yeah so he
started putting pieces together that I
didn't I didn't even know he was
involved in that till that Kevin Costner
movie came out talking about the Cuban
Missile Crisis my dad started crying in
front of me first time I've ever seen
him cry
and uh and I finally asked him like why
are you so emotional over this and then
he you know told me this whole thing he
was one of the keepers of the Dragon
which they called this small group of
people that took care of the atomic bomb
that loaded it up they got it ready
there was a partial engineer job and
and so these guys were the harbors of
this nuclear bomb
and so he was around that so that
obviously the stress and the craziness
of that he never shared it
um but the one thing that it left him
with was an absolute annihilation of of
his thyroid right so then then the
radioactive exposure yeah yeah I mean so
so he was already hijacked from an
ionizing radiation which pulls apart
electrons and destroys DNA
um and very acutely
um uh has an affinity for the thyroid so
he didn't have that and so as I'm
putting these pieces together and seeing
kind of the front row of his life and
then it's almost like if you have this
glass here
his immune system his liver was
compromised of alcoholism and and then
this compromised uh endocrine system and
a a thyroid that was gone
and then you add on top of it this
exposure this this level of depression
that would come in and had very little
resiliency so it's as if if I took this
water and I filled up this glass and it
kind of spilled over he had he did not
have a normal level of resiliency to
just kind of live his life right and I'm
very
um I my conclusion is that that led him
down with forced retirement with a
disability because he he couldn't
educate his wing at the college right he
couldn't do it fast enough to get people
to like hey man I have this thing called
chemical sensitivity he would make he
was a teacher so he'd make tapes he
would find all the research and he would
send it to everybody all of his
colleagues and everything else and
um and then he had to retire and then
slowly he had to start giving up
parts of his life and he was very
sociable he loved connecting with people
he cared deeply and and when things were
kind of being taken away from him
because of this invisible thing that he
couldn't abuse started showing back up
in his life after 30 years of sobriety
I'm convinced it's yeah it's a absolute
strong
uh situation that that led him to
feeling not so great and then ultimately
alcohol claimed his life right forced
forced isolation
leading leading to that relapse yeah
yeah it's tragic you know it's really
it's it's really sad but it's also
powerful you know it's perhaps the most
powerful example that you have to kind
of set the stage to talk about these
invisible forces that are at play that
you know we didn't consent to even
before birth as you mentioned and you
quote an amazing study that uh I think
that was the environmental working group
did where they tested like umbilical
cord you know like umbilical cords of
babies and realizing how Rife with all
kinds of chemicals and and toxins
existed there you know prior to birth
200 plus and and 75 over 75 percent of
them are known problematic
uh cancer uh utero problems birth
defects Etc and that and that's how
we're starting
life uh and you're like you know that
that's a
and now with you know
pre and pro
floral Alkali substances called pfos
these things now are in over 90 of of
Red Cross did this over 90 percent of
everyone's blood
is pfas and that's that's a for everyone
listening that's in a class of compounds
called Forever chemicals forever
right
and that that is I was thinking on the
way over I was like what's the most
startling because so many times how many
swear words are in here when I'm going
through research going what the [__] is
happening right how is this possible
pfos is pretty gnarly because not only
are they forever chemicals and we've had
examples of them too
you know we've had examples of other
forever chemicals DDT
was banned in 1972 and guess what is in
over 90 of all teenagers today
DDT I saw that in the book that was
shocking because you would think that's
that's by that's a bygone like that that
doesn't exist anymore we we got our [__]
together when it came to that yeah and
it's like and this is where it goes into
in the again Rich we have so many rabbit
holes who go down let's try to keep it
on the rails but it go but it goes and
people are going
yeah but how is it
that these things even exist and there's
a million examples in the book right
how are these things even in the book
well there's there's a couple ways to
answer that there's plausible
deniability
right so plausible deniability is
basically well
if we don't test it
in our product then we don't know what's
there we don't know it's harmful and
then if you look at some of the studies
you're clearly showing in other
randomized controlled trials that is
causing harm and mammals and mice and
all these other things
so
the game those come out with the game
the game is
we're going to put
whatever we want for the most part
in these products
and then if there's a problem
and if there's an overwhelming amount of
a problem then the quote unquote
government
regulatory bodies will step in and then
do something about it right so you know
we talked I think before we even
recording like it's a moving Target like
this book every week there was more
stuff coming out and
even before being done and now there was
um simply Simply Orange uh got busted by
the Coca-Cola company and full of a
bunch of crazy stuff but you know what
they found 200.
pfos chemicals in that being sold Simply
Orange is the orange juice brand yeah
it's an orange juice brand by the
Coca-Cola company so
they didn't test it so they quote
unquote didn't know right right so yeah
uh
just to kind of tie the knot on pfos and
we can talk about more talk about that
more if you like uh that was something
that that I talked extensively about
with Aaron Brockovich with respect to
water and what's going on with water you
know shocking you can go and listen to
that we spent two hours talking about
pfos and then I had
Craig Renfrew on who's the founder of
beauty counter she created this amazing
company uh to produce
um personal care products for women that
were toxin free and has been loud and
and very powerful voice on Capitol Hill
lobbying for change but you know some of
what she shared you know mimics or just
overlaps perfectly with what you're
saying here basically
I mean first of all I don't know if this
has changed but she shared that the
United States had not passed any major
legislation on the safety of ingredients
and personal care products since 1939
and essentially you know the kind of
quote that you have in the book on this
is that that she talks about is
is this this burden of proof right like
basically
it's not a situation in which the
company who's about to put a product on
the Shelf has to prove that it's safe uh
it can just go into use and only when
evidence mounts that it's dangerous not
just dangerous but that the danger is
overwhelming and impossible to ignore
will the government get involved or
people file lawsuits or or what have you
so that's all broken and reversed and
when you look at the very long list of
chemicals that find their way into all
of these products that are just sort of
like well they're safe or you know they
do these internal uh studies right like
they either don't study it before it
goes on the shelf or they do a
self-serving study to say yeah we've
we've looked at it it's safe and it's
kind of a roulette wheel right and
meanwhile we you know another kind of
overarching theme in the book that you
make very clear is that we're living in
an experiment I'm glad that you've had a
couple badasses on this podcast to talk
about this because I I I need to
as as way through the legacy of of my
first teacher it was my dad you know so
I have to talk about it and I know it's
affecting people and then
so yeah I mean the the the pfos thing is
so crazy and so it is and it is
absolutely reversed so we think this is
the internal fatal convenience of
Regulation
that in of itself is a fatal convenience
of how this is happening it's a Twilight
Zone of an experiment as opposed to
shouldn't it be proven safe
before we can blast it out to our
children and put this very easy wipeable
baby bib on our beautiful child when
that easy wipeable baby bib is full of
pfos because it's a non-sticking easy to
wipe off and just for context for
everybody because they should go back
and listen to those other podcasts that
you've mentioned
it is a grandson of Teflon right it's
this fluorine reaction chemical reaction
that goes on and it shows up just to
give a couple examples
every time you see something saying like
a wrinkle free run the other way when
that mascara doesn't come off
don't use it all of these things and
packaging the the you know not that you
and I partake in in fast food but that
that the food doesn't stick to the
wrappers pfos yeah that was the the fast
food wrapper one was one I didn't know
yeah talk about explain that one yeah so
I mean they used this again they're
taking what is think thankfully
how many years later being banned in the
coding of pans which is the kind of the
origin story of Teflon yeah we all know
as children of the 70s we all remember
that the non-stick pans and and all of
that that you know finally
but they're still then they're like well
okay well let's just use it in these
other areas where we don't have to that
no one knows about them no one needs to
talk about them so Gore-Tex right so
rain resistant
um stain resistant carpets
um food packaging so so all of these
slippery kind of surfaces
they're all derivatives of this known
probable as they say carcinogen
and endocrine disruptor so
so just as a context
almost everyone has it in their blood
and they're doing and and also to
understand that the numbers are
staggering there's nine thousand
different forms of pfas
in our environment nine thousand right
so we're getting hit unknowingly and
we're not voting for that so you know I
go back to okay let's let's become aware
of this stuff
so that we can make another choice and
that's really where all of this comes
from like Rich you know just to be
straight up
I did not want to write I didn't know I
didn't want to have to write a book like
this
but when you realize the regulation
bodies
aren't regulating they're just reacting
to that uh Cascade that happens that
then the government has to step in but
the toxic substance control act so think
about it
the toxic control substance Act was
initiated because of pfas
to then give permission for the
regulatory bodies to then regulate
you're like what you didn't what like
everything I'm reading this all of this
stuff and it's everything's the opposite
like you said and and this is where
people going I don't get it so if I go
into a store
and if I don't know which product to
choose that doesn't have these things
and you're getting exposed to not only
pfos but BPA BPH uh pcbs ddts uh heavy
metals and and the next question is how
is that possible and the first thing
answer I would say I don't know yeah
that was you know by obvious next
question given that there are uh you
know good faith actors out there trying
to you know influence the landscape we
have we mentioned the environmental
working group like they do great work
you know people like Paul Hawkins
yourself uh you know they're out there
you know trying to educate the public
but this seems to be really locked in
like what is it about our system that is
so resistant to uh protecting the public
when it comes to this kind of stuff I
mean dude I mean the only place I can go
is we created a false god right and that
false god is this prophet
over the health and safety like it's
reversed so
you know let's just put all this stuff
out and if it's a problem we'll deal
with all of this later you know and so
I don't understand it I don't know why
it is but that whole thing is reversed
and but you know I always go to the
optimism of all of this stuff the
optimism is having these conversations
so that you and I can amplify the
message of Regular People
realizing that this is what it is
there is a huge amount of chemical
exposure on average an average woman
every day is getting hit with over a
hundred different chemicals all of which
are some sort of form of endocrine
disruption carcinogenic uh ammonium
salts the breast tissue from deodorants
you know it just goes on and on and on
so this is in order for us
to change we need to face it we need to
go okay this is realism 101 what's
happening this is what's happening this
is why I had to hire 25 people and fact
Checkers and like pay them and like work
my ass off to get through all of this
stuff so that we can face this honestly
and then the optimism comes by
the 8 billion people we have we have the
numbers so as we wake up as we then go
oh okay well I'm not saying don't use
cell phones don't wash your hair maybe
do a little less of them right
um
that we can change from not this
to this right we have better Solutions
obviously a third of the book is
littered with solutions for these things
so that's the Hope right and I I use
this example Rich of like you know you
and I
I spent a lot of time together and and
we know that uh
in order to have real good relationships
you gotta face not only yourself with
radical honesty you gotta face people
and people in your life with radical
honesty and have these these very
healthy but direct truthful
conversations this is the same this is
the same thing right
I wish this wasn't the case I wish all
these chemicals weren't blasting you and
me and our children with all of this
stuff but it's it is what we were born
into so I I'm not okay with it I saw my
dad suffer firsthand and I just want to
face it honestly to then uplift support
and create the waves of continued change
so that we can celebrate the people
putting Lavender in as opposed to a
trade secret endocrine disrupting
carcinogenic property of a formula that
they weirdly don't have to disclose
because they just call it a trade secret
like let's not reward that let's let's
reward the people the the the companies
that are trying to do the right thing
it's better for you it's better for the
people around you in the case of
colognes and perfume uh and it's
ultimately better for the environment
that's where I love
which became very clear to me in the
writing of this thing that
well we are an ecosystem right so if
these chemicals are severely affecting
my ecosystem maybe it's changing my
microbiome or my skin affecting the
sebum production because I've put some
sort of weird ass lotion on my body all
of these things how they are created
what they are from in their
environmental side of things where the
production side of things are also an
equally destroying parts of the
environment so
as it hurts you it hurts the environment
so you want to be an Eco Warrior
clean this stuff up in your In Yourself
clean up all of these these exposures
and it's not about trying to be perfect
it's just trying to make one better
choice every time because that's the
Journey of Life anyway yeah sure
um I love the idea of radical honesty
and and kind of emerging out of this uh
you know state of denial you know
there's a there's a sort of blissful
ignorance about how we make our consumer
choices right we've talked a lot about
factory farming and the AG gag laws like
there's a lot of money to erect barriers
to prevent the level of transparency
that would connect the consumer with how
our food is actually made because it's
abhorrent and if people knew maybe they
would think twice right so there's a lot
of uh interest in maintaining the status
quo and preventing any level of radical
honesty because people like things that
are convenient and they like things that
are easily accessible and cheap and
that's what we have right now and just
go to the mall and knock yourself out
right and and to have this conversation
is to tell people like hold on a second
you know you might want to know that all
these other things are happening some
people are going to be very resistant
because
to know that
requires them that to then have to
consider their choices and that's
uncomfortable you know that is that is
that is like you know you're asking a
lot of somebody to do that and yet here
we are
you know in the situation we're in with
you know global climate change and all
of that like there's never been a more
urgent or better time nor a more
receptive Global audience to these ideas
uh so yes this conversation is is
overdue and we're dealing with a
capitalist system that's very entrenched
in a certain level of status quo they
like it the way that it is they don't
want people to know that the genes that
they're wearing have you know a
bazillion Downstream you know negative
implications not just for the humans
that are wearing them but for the
workers that are manufacturing them and
for everything that like you know ends
up in the water table as a result of the
dyes and the runoffs and the
microplastics ETC it's quite shocking to
hear all of that it is a matrix
situation and it's a lot like it's
overload like if you sat down and read
this book from beginning to end your
head would explode right so like how do
you even you know begin I mean I guess
before we go any further maybe like give
me your definition of what a fatal
convenience is we're like 40 minutes in
and we haven't even like defined what
we're talking about here but I think
people get it but go ahead yeah well you
know it a fatal convenience is you're
doing something I can easily grab this
this water and drink it
it's convenient it's a you know many
places around the world can turn on uh
you don't have access to clean water so
that's a convenience
the fatal side of it comes in
here's that nasty pfos that shows up
again here's the nitrates that come by
the runoff of the of the the glyphosates
and the fertilizers and everything else
the microplastics are now showing up in
the waterways so
so it's
things that you're doing
living your modern day life
and not realizing
have kind of a a punch to your system
your life that you're not realizing you
have you know people having more and
more depressive disorders more and more
endometriosis for women like uh the the
list cancers
um all of these things cardiovascular uh
linked to some of these perfumes and
things like that so we can naively move
forward
but we are our biology our chemistry our
being is being affected by these things
every day all day and so to pretend sure
it's it's shocking to people and I think
the thing that's
the biggest thing is it starts to
rewrite
your idea of reality
because
if you start to really grock what we
said earlier about
wait what that
they can just put this stuff out on the
market and aren't really responsible
unless there's an overwhelming response
then we'll step in
that has to many people don't get that
many people in the world don't realize
that this is an experiment and they're
putting 60 to 80
000 chemicals in our environment every
year and of that only about 1500 are
tested
and just individually tested none zero
zilch are tested as they interact with
themselves or us so it's it's an
impossibility
for
in some cases to find one Smoking Gun
right in another instance to really get
your head around all of this exposure
exposure and then so you go
wow not all products most of which in
the personal care space and Beauty space
and clothing
actually have very dangerous
consequences and it's not that you're
putting on the pair of blue jeans and
it's killing you tomorrow
it's this
accumulative body burden right so so the
rebuttal argument to all of these
chemicals and all of these products that
that you know billions of people are
using every single day is that they are
being delivered in such micro doses as
to be you know at to be you know neutral
and not harmful like they're they're
benign they're inert because it's so
tiny so the response to that is is
twofold on the one hand it's what you
just stated this idea of allostatic load
like over the course of your lifetime
yeah but you know yeah like in this one
laundry detergent or in this bar of soap
or whatever it's it it's so uh
microscopic you don't have to worry
about it but you know your wash your
hair you'd be like soap you do it then
then you eat the you know the
cheeseburger for lunch and then you have
the Monster Energy drink and then you
and then you you know you put on your
blue jean like you're just you're you're
basically like just constantly you know
impulsing your body through hundreds if
not thousands of of different chemical
inputs every single day so there's that
load over time
um because a lot of these chemicals have
a short half-life compared to the
forever chemicals the pfoses right so
there's a conversation around that and
then second to that is
is and I found this very interesting I
learned a lot about this in your book is
it ignores the infinite complexity and
interplay of all of these different
chemicals interacting with each other
which makes it impossible to study or
evaluate because you don't know what the
chemical from your Monster Energy Drink
is going how what what that is going to
do when it interacts with you know the
glyphosate that found its way into your
system because of the factory farmed
whatever that you ate
yeah it is and that's where it gets just
completely crazy right and so you talk
about these Half-Life so you've got like
things like BPA and uh uh phthalates
which which have sometimes just a few
hours or maybe maybe a day or so
and and then that that's where oh that's
fine right it's fine they there's some
studies on it but that's not the real
world when you actually look at the
studies showing real world like the one
of the Shockers was oxy uh benzone
benzoine which is in most of the
sunscreens like yeah they studied it
like oh small enough doses but how it's
applied and what shows up in the blood
was somewhere between 500 times
more
so it's in the real world is massively
different so these people if they do do
studies they it's so limited and not
realistic and like I said none of them
are the interaction so okay you woke up
you went in a shower it wasn't filtered
okay so you've got microplastics pfos
you know volatile organic compounds vocs
all while you're showering right you're
using a body wash using shampoo you're
using a conditioner all of that parabens
phthalates
fragrances right then you're getting out
of the shower and you're putting on a
lotion right right well first of all
you're drying off with a towel that is
what you know like has all these dyes on
it right yes so that's full again you
can literally you've been awake for five
minutes yeah yeah yeah exactly and and
and and then maybe had a glass of water
that you didn't filter or whatever it is
um and then yeah so now you're so
exposure exposure exposure exposure then
you're putting on your your mask mascara
and your makeup and your God forbid you
ever use regular perfume after reading
this book again there's great again
there's amazing choices essential oils
and things that are frankly frankincense
and myrrh yeah
gotta get like biblical yeah I mean like
I mean come on Rose and lavender and
like there's just a great companies that
that that and it's also gifting to other
people around you so the point is that
okay some of those half-lifes of the
parabens and the phthalates and maybe
even the fragrances are a few hours but
but you're also
re-infecting yourself all throughout the
day right and then you're putting on
your deodorants and the uh ammonium
salts are interacting and proven through
carcinogenic activity of of binding to
the and and clogging up the pores and
creating all kinds of Xeno activity so
you know all of these things
um it's that again that overall body
burden the accumulation and and that's
where you know
just looking at it all you're these are
just think of them as stressors
stress stress stress stress stress
stress stress on a cellular deep level
and
you know I think the job is the the
intention is to slowly
kind of from the inside out you know
opening your mouth extremely vulnerable
to the world right so Choose Wisely you
know what are you drinking what is it
interacting with what are you eating
what is it interacting with so what do
you you know the water the you know cans
aluminum chelating uh heavy metals uh
what's in my food all of that stuff
and then work your way out from there
okay what's going on my skin because
there's a lot of transdermal activity of
these chemicals and they're going into
your skin I just did it wasn't even the
book I just did a fatal convenience
because I do these on my podcast all the
time I just did one on the on the the
Shaving strips
scared the [__] out of me and I'm like I
was like um
I suspect something with these and again
there was
monoethylenes in there there's
um which are endocrine disrupting
there's other ammonium salts in there
that think about it like the glue for
you know stripping hair off your face or
your legs or whatever yeah yeah all of
that stuff so a shaving shaving with the
strip so that's what I mean the shade
the strip on that lubricating on the
actual yeah I see yeah so on the razor
itself yeah what a convenience No Shave
Burns blah blah blah but then again
you're shaving and you're also micro
cutting so all those chemicals are
basically just going right into your
bloodstream so yeah I would have never
thought of that yeah and this is what I
mean like the the the
the apathy because we're born into this
right and it's all around us the apathy
that we have
come accustomed to that we stop thinking
my whole but that burden shouldn't be on
us like it's not that we're apathetic
like are we supposed to go I wonder if
that strip on my thing is going to harm
me like we shouldn't have to go down the
rabbit hole that you went down to figure
out whether that's safe or not I know
that's what I mean I wish I never had to
write this book I I do yeah you know I
have a busy life I've got a lot to do
you know I took two weekends off in two
years
because every weekend it was less
distracting and I spent just a huge
amount of time on the every day all day
Saturday Sunday
man I have a lot to do but it's like
when you read when you learn the Matrix
just keeps going man and it just like
and you know those things where it's
like
with awareness and knowledge become you
know you have greater responsibility as
a result
um
and being that it was very close to home
watching my father suffer
my whole like
like it's a little
uh you know I see Life in fatal
conveniences now you know the greatest
kind of
um inspiration for learning about fatal
conveniences is leaving my environment
yeah where you control every minute yeah
my new detail and I just go out going oh
my God
people still use that
like I went home I saw my mom still
using vaseline on her face right that's
just straight up petroleum wiping on her
face for the last 50 years right and so
I see this stuff happening
uh and and I I can't help myself but to
go up you know I'm always texting my
team like okay this one's next for the
Fatal convenience this one's next and
you know that's that's the job at this
point it's just you know the the book is
a conversation starter about a lot of
things I could have that could have been
a volume series of 20. yeah all based in
fatal conveniences so my hope is that
people can just open it up
obviously I want them to read it all the
way through to get the context of
everything because we we dedicated
certain parts of the book
um certainly pfos
uh emfs you're setting things up going
okay this is what's have personal care
uh you know all of these things you're
setting up so that people have a good
understanding of of what you're then
going to give them specific examples too
um so that they can go oh my God here it
is again yeah yeah yeah
before you go and buy a mattress or buy
bed sheets or laundry detergent maybe
just you know find the find the pages in
the book and refer to that first yeah
you know because a lot of the stuff we
sort of know like you know whether we
know processed foods you know factory
farming these things are you know things
that we should avoid there's some of the
you know kind of more obvious stuff but
there's a lot of things in here that are
that are not obvious like I think
mattresses is what you know would would
be in that category or you know a
discussion around off-gassing or you
know some of the really what we think
are just completely mundane products
that we use to wash our fans or our
clothes totally yeah yeah and you know
the the
again it's this invisible world that I'm
trying to make more visible on top of
that you talked about
the Oneness of our own personal
ecosystems and the greater ecosystem of
the planet there's of course the sort of
chemical inputs of of these of these
products whether they're food clothing
Personal Care cleaning products Etc you
know on our on our bodies in our bodies
what that is doing to us but then of
course as you kind of you know uh the
nesting egg expands outward you're like
well the packaging that it's coming in
or even if the packaging doesn't seem
particularly malevolent what's the liner
inside the packet the paper packaging
you know what does that look like and
where did that come from and how is that
made and is that coming into contact
with me and then there's the
manufacturing process itself like how
are these things being made what are the
what are the things that what are the
inputs that are creating this what is
the carbon footprint of all of those
inputs aggregated and what is the the
runoff like what's happening to our
water table where are all the chemicals
you know ending up on the planet like
how are we processing the waste Etc we
know this with for example you know Pig
farming and the you know the all the
refuse and how that gets turned into
fertilizer and gets sprayed into the air
and people have respiratory diseases and
all the like but it's really not that
different with any number of these other
Industries yeah you know particularly
clothing fast fashion and you know we're
really asleep at the wheel when it comes
to that that was a sleeper for me when I
really started looking at oh my God
that's a big problem like it's a number
two biggest polluter on the planet you
don't kind of you can't get your head
around because it's easy to demonize a
water bottle because it's floating out
in the river in the ocean and then you
go okay you can get your head around
it's gonna break down in the micro
Plastics well most of the clothes are
woven with petroleum and Plastics and
plasticizers and formaldehydes and
things like that and that that tightly
formed shirt and t-shirt that you love
so much the the elastic jeans yeah
anything that like stretches a little
bit yeah big problem and people are you
know women are going to be like yeah
that Lycra
not a good thing right so that Lycra is
a petroleum-based uh endocrine
disrupting and now that now you're
sweating in it you're using it it's
close to your private parts uh these
things that's constant inoculation of of
these chemicals and you think like one
of great example is the iconics which
are a T-shirt and blue jeans
and some of the shock came by
the not only the the thousands of liters
of water there's one that I couldn't
verify but I'm just gonna throw it out
there for shock value but I was trying
to verify it
it was one report said that it was about
two 2500 liters of water from input of
growing the cotton to creating one
t-shirt now I dug into that a little
more it's hundreds
of leaders without a doubt per t-shirt
but you have
8 000.
you heard that right 8
000 chemicals
that are there to create a t-shirt
8 000 different chemicals so you've got
the chemicals and and
glyphosate astrazine
huge spring one of the biggest polluters
and uses of of that of those pesticides
on your
non-organic clothing t-shirt right so
now you're starting already there
um and then they're blasting you know
before they write they blast now it's a
technique now they blast with more right
before uh picking they blast with more
and
um
then that goes to the stripping and the
spinning and all of that stuff so those
8 000 chemicals are now what makes that
t-shirt not to mention if you have any
print on that that's full of these
things called Azo dies that are not only
volatile organic compounds connected to
um cancer and things like that so that's
a t-shirt man
like that's [__] up it's it's so so
it's but that what do you say to the the
person who's like I hear you man but
aren't you a little bit uh Chicken
Little here I've been wearing t-shirts
for 50 years like I feel pretty good I'm
fine I don't have cancer like what do
you say to that person you're you're an
alarmist Yeah Yeah well yeah that's a
great question like
um I'm not saying that t-shirt put that
t-shirt on today I'm not saying it kills
you tomorrow
I'm saying that T-shirt be aware of how
it was created
all of the things that are definitely in
that shirt
and it's again the community that this
this growing body burden of all of this
stuff now it's connected to the
destruction of the environment we can
prove that upside down and sideways it's
more of that chemical burden that's
being put on you so I I say
not to not not even getting into the the
the
horrible conditions of fast fashion
right
um right the human rights issue human
rights issue the slavery that basically
happens in order for you to get that
cheap t-shirt
what I would like to say is that if you
can resist
getting insecure that you don't have
enough clothes and maybe double down on
you know one new t-shirt every year and
if you can use organic and not sprayed
in formaldehydes and phthalates and
things like that anything so is that
shampoo killing you is that lotion
killing you tomorrow no but it's setting
the stage for you to wake up one day and
really have an issue then and the the
the the the build up of these chemicals
we we are starting to see it we see it
in these numbers so we see it in the
plummeting of testosterone we're seeing
it in like I said the reproductive
issues of women uh infertilities of men
the motility the activity of sperm is is
plummeting
um Dr Leo trasande has a great book on
endocrine disruptor I think it's called
sicker fatter poorer he Dives deep I've
had him on my podcast he Dives deep in
the endocrine disruptions got a lot of
great numbers on that but the we're
sprinting towards our own demise like
literally the the most Primal aspect of
us as humans to keep life moving
we are neutering ourselves with all of
these things right it has been shown
even with children and diapers having
the plastic throwaway diapers that those
kids have higher amounts of phthalates
and endocrine disrupting and they it and
they don't have a choice
so my whole thing is then
why don't we go back to get those
parents organic uh reusable washable
diapers and just eliminate part of that
exposure yeah the diapers thing was a
trip I mean when you imagine you know a
newborn a pristine newborn and then
you're immediately you know placing on
on on on this brand new human skin a
product that I think you said that they
found glyphosate yeah in disposable
diapers formaldehyde
DBP d e HP hormone disruptors like all
this like
it's insane yeah and that's where it
it's yeah and like what that's going on
in the world that that can be sold and
listen
if I had a wand and I could
let every Mama Bear
who loves their kids obviously and and
has instinct to
pull cars off their kids right want to
protect want their kids to thrive want
them to be healthy
and then you go
they didn't know they weren't informed
at all
about these convenience that keep being
sold to them well it's easier it's
convenient it's
Pampers this and so
if they knew that so let's flip on the
switch of Mama bears to realize that the
exposures that are coming not only the
food the the the talc that got alarmed
uh formula yeah the formula the heavy
metals the all of these things the
exposure and like again we go to how is
this possible I don't know man
I don't know
but you and I have to continue to talk
about it and I I hope that people can
just continue to learn and expand and
become their regulatory body of their
body that's what yeah you can't
Outsource uh these decisions to
governmental bodies that you're relying
upon for solid information like that's
that's really you know the kind of drum
that you're banging throughout this book
like you gotta shoulder that
responsibility for yourself this is very
much a message around you know the
Grassroots movement and the power of
community the power of the individual to
not just have these conversations to
make better choices and to you know
cultivate Community around this so that
change can come from the bottom up
we can't sit around and just wait for
Washington to deal with it I had I had
Senator Cory Booker on the podcast
recently and and one of the things that
he says all the time is change change
doesn't come from Washington it comes to
Washington right like Washington
responds to
these sorts of movements so that's an
added kind of responsibility to shoulder
as a conscious citizen totally right and
if enough people get together and
make their voices heard there will be
you know a response on Capitol Hill but
to sit on our hands and just wait for
that to happen it's not going to happen
and when you kind of you know when your
eyes are open and you look around and
you realize we can't even solve the real
low-hanging fruit problems like why do
we have single-use Plastics like why is
water allowed to be in a plastic bottle
anymore like it should be it should be
that should be it's a law like I think
most people would agree on that these
are not you know partisan issues by any
stretch of the imagination yeah and yet
you know we'll get all excited about
straws for a minute or you know we get
distracted by the wrong thing
when we have these real big problems
with so it's not like we don't have
solutions to these problems that's
that's the other thing too and and you
know you're very robust uh appendix and
all the resources make clear like you
know this doesn't you don't have to
be like Darren and like live in the
woods and you know in a yard or whatever
like you can still you don't have to be
a lot like you can live in the world and
you don't have to be really all that
convenienced at all
um you can just make some better choices
yeah and that's that's where I I'm
optimistic number one I want people to
live a freaking great life I want them
to I mean ultimately the the Genesis of
super life the Genesis of this is hey
man like let's be aware so that you can
actually live a dream that you want to
have and be in this world and that's
really where it comes from and so we
just have to face some of the stuff be
be our own advocacy and uh and and flip
on that switch of Common Sense again
that I guess you know
maybe that's jumping a step because we
just first need to become aware of the
system that's not in our best interest
um but I am optimistic every week I and
I'm not even being dramatic every week
I'm talking to an organization a company
that's doing something better right if
it's uh we talked a little bit uh before
we start about like the Michael Works
company and the mycelium leather stuff
and that you know people only realize
like leather has pfos on it right
because it does you know that's slippery
stuff too so it's like all of these
things are so affected but there's
there's
there's great people doing great things
and even in great companies they're
trying to do good now there's there's
tons of really cool Innovation so I
would agree with you on that front I
think an added Ripple of complexity to
all of this that that began as something
well-intentioned but now has become
almost a smoke screen is the whole
labeling thing right like now there's
all these labels on all these products
uh and we don't really know like is this
what does this mean like is this mean
anything or did was this botton paid for
like I don't know which labels are
important which ones are just green
washing so maybe we can have just a
conversation you know initially just
broadly about what is green washing what
is the extent of green washing and you
know how can we as as you know conscious
consumers who do want to make the right
choice you know how do we how do we kind
of interface with all the marketing and
stuff that's on the the you know the
packaging of the products that we're
looking to buy yeah it's a good one I
mean green washing only came about
because of the Lexicon that's moving
towards hey man I wanna I wanna have a
better choice a normal person there was
a great study a normal person doesn't
actually want to drink out of a water
bottle of plastic they just don't have
another choice you know if you go on an
airline you just you're dealing with it
so the Lexicon of the people the
population of people do have this
awareness they just don't have many
choices so what happens is these big
organizations doesn't even have to be
big
take this kind of atmosphere and they
start labeling things that are
misleading and and and misleading
without the proper backing
of what they're actually saying or
they're saying natural it's a classic
one that has no backing of what that
means plus all natural yeah yeah or they
just put it in a green they just the
packaging is a beautiful picture just
put it yeah like you have a couple
different varieties of the same product
one is one is green I'm just gonna take
that that one's probably better I'm
gonna get that one yeah it's green it's
got a great picture and it says uh this
is a natural scent well
you know having 15 years 20 years in the
supplement world I knew that there was a
problem even then in the in the
flavoring World there was this natural
flavor but then the FDA had all these
loopholes to have other flow agents uh
things in there so it's the same that
exists in these kind of other areas and
fragrances in the sense that
okay you have natural scent in this
example
but then you have trade secrets that
could have hundreds of chemicals that
are not on any label and the the
phraseology you're using
is just misleading the people towards
this all you did is not change any
formula you didn't make it better you
didn't make it safe you didn't prove
that it's safe you didn't prove that it
was actually naturally safe but you just
put a beautiful picture on it you called
it something and now you're taking the
the the the movement that actually does
want to make that innately we do want to
make good choices we don't knowingly
want to hurt our kid by making a a
choice of a scented candle that's it got
vocs all over it but they're calling it
natural scent you know so all of these
things they're taking advantage of an
impossible
a group
large population of people that are not
doing the incredible research that it
would take to unpack what that actually
means in that natural sense and that's
not okay it's not okay at all it would
be benign if these things were benign
but they're not benign there are they
are hijacking are
are systems they are affecting us
neurologically carcinogenic uh endocrine
disrupting uh testicular cancers uh
endometriosis the list continues and it
grows at this mounting kind of loop so
the the green washing is knowingly this
is where it comes in the the companies
are knowingly
misleading people yeah that's what makes
it so malevolent right I mean they're
leveraging language and loopholes to
um delude the consumer into this you
know sense that they're making a good
choice for themselves when in fact it's
business as usual and you know we see
this in the animal food industry with
words or phrases like you know cage-free
or you know free range and all of that
and like and it makes you think oh
cage-free yeah of course or but you
don't actually know what that means in
the in the real language that polices
you know what's acceptable and what's
not I think would be shocking to a lot
of people and it just drives a lot of
um
apathy is the wrong word but I think it
lulls people into a sense that they are
participating in the solution when in
fact they're not and that's what makes
it particularly dark I think and and you
know I don't know if Evil's the right
word but like you know not great right
and so for the person who it but there
are some labels that are good right like
if it's ewg whatever certified like
they're so like if somebody's going to
the store and they're they're like okay
now there's like 10 different little
certifications on every product that is
even in the range of being like oh this
is like a you know like a natural
organic conscious non-GMO whatever
what are the labels that are actually
legit that people should look for and
what are the ones that are [__] and
misleading
well some of the ones that are
misleading is recyclable
like so you could put recyclable on a
Packaging
like here's the product it's in a
package recyclable
and you're like great maybe it was a
shower curtain
all of it was made out of plastic what's
recyclable is it the packaging that's
recyclable is the rings of the shower
curtain recyclable is the
vinyl weird thing that you're putting is
that recyclable
you don't know and most of most of it
probably isn't and then just going off
on a tangent for a second on recycling
because you're again you're wanting to
do it
you separate your things and being a
good person I'm recycling I'm going to
the effort but now new reports even show
it's even worse only five percent of
whatever you think you're recycling is
recycled in any storm for we so so we
failed miserably so that's like saying
take your little blue bin
dump out 95 of it and that 95 percent is
and I say this in the book
is
there's no let me say it this way
there's no away
take my cycle recycling away go recycle
it
there virtually is none
it's not virtually non-existent only
five percent right when you put your
your refuse in the recycling bin and it
comes and it gets picked up by the
garbage truck what is that yeah like
they're a very small fraction of that
five percent yeah yeah yeah which is
really disheartening so dump out 95 and
stare at it and going could I maybe
be a little better
at not consuming so much that is using
plastic or whatever or whatever kind of
garbage it is that we think most of it
it's so layered the the sophistication
at recycling centers they can't unravel
hell most people don't even know that
there's a plastic liner in Starbucks
coffee and I'm not picking on Starbucks
but there's a plastic liner in that what
you think is a cardboard oh they're
they're they're oh they're paper cups
yeah they're paper cups so they say hey
use a paper cup it's not
plastic liner in it so you can't recycle
it
right you think you're throwing a
cardboard but and you can't recycle it
because there's no ability for most of
the recycling centers to break that
apart and to like put it back in the
cardboard circulation put it back in the
plastic so all of these things are
infinitely complex
so even saying those words don't mean
much but it's still a green washing if
you're
negligent on what you actually mean
right so you know there's uh I'm not
even going to name the company but there
is because it would cause me a lot of
problems with people I know uh there was
one company that's like hey yeah
recyclable and then you gotta eat this
thing this bar and then you send it back
to the company and like who's gonna do
that right and you're just just take the
take the packaging and mail it back to
them yeah okay yeah right okay now
you're gonna so so again you use that as
a marketing spin but the percentage of
people actually doing that is a few
percent right if at all so yeah that's a
it's a I forgot the second party
question I mean the main question like
and so what are the labels that are
valid and can can you know give us
confidence that we are making a good
choice
ah
it's a good one yeah I mean it's a good
one this came up in in Sea spiricy do
you remember like the labeling on on
fish and all of that and how corrupt it
was and it's basically a pay-to-play
thing yeah yeah so like the the dolphin
free was definitely not at all basically
um
Dolphins safe yeah right yeah yeah okay
um so yeah it you know
from uh you know starting from like
maybe food from a low residue
um pesticide perspective you can go all
the way back to pick number nine on the
little sticker on Whole Food four and
three is indicating pesticides and GMOs
and stuff like that so if there's no
sign you can look at the little stickers
the stickers that are on the price so
you don't pick nine so that's not even
that's just a part of the they're
categorizing for the grocery store so
you can hack your way into know at least
what that is uh there's the
environmental working group has a great
list of The Dirty Dozen if you if you
don't
have access or can't afford organic then
you want to wash
uh the exposed vegetables and fruit like
you know things like pears
strawberries peaches cucumbers like the
those kind of things
um you want to wash really well and you
can eliminate a lot of the
um
residues that way but you don't want to
just eat those straight away
um
yeah and then of course organic like you
want to choose that I would still wash
those Foods uh and then you all go all
if you want to keep going farmers
markets know your farmer how are you
growing it ask them questions get to
know them uh and then you know grow your
own food you know let's bring back that
uh piece because that could help you
know a variety of
things food security
uh clearly can help out a lot and um you
know we have you know in the
late 1800s 90 of the of Americans were
uh
using their land as their food right and
now now two percent right of of the
farmers uh of the people in the country
are making all of our food so that's a
whole Rabbit Hole of the Agricultural
side so
get to know your food grow as much as
you can
um but I don't like that like like for
personal care products or cleaning
products is there any kind of
responsible labeling going on in you
know other kind of consumer product
sectors
um yeah I mean you you can I mean the
the best thing is to
first indication is what kind of
packaging they're using because you can
also see the the the the the kind of the
scope of what the company is trying to
do
um if they're just standard plastic then
okay
um
but I would turn it over
you know it's that whole thing of like
if you can understand what your special
like personal care and lotions and
things like that if they don't have you
know phthalates well you don't know they
have phthalates but if they're in
plastic containers they probably have
phthalates in because the plast
phthalates are the plasticizers that
make plastic malleable right
um so so I I think the best thing to do
is make sure when they're if they're
saying parfum or or or fragrance and
they're not
proudly disclosing what that is for them
and it's like this is lavender this is
rose essential oil then I would run like
for sure you're going to be getting a
cocktail
um so though and fragrances are
something to become aware of because
they're they're almost in every beauty
product uh personal care so if a company
is proudly saying what their fragrance
is
um then that's a probably a good
indicator of a natural kind of rest of
the formula and and then you want to
look for
you know
whole uh things that you can yeah you
know pronounce yeah yeah yeah and
understand yeah the common sense aspect
of it I was just wondering whether
there's like some kind of you know
chi-ching thing like right on the pad oh
I know okay but if there's not like yes
campaign for safe Cosmetics I don't know
if they have a a symbol ewg does they do
great work I was I'm still kind of hint
kind of playing with the idea of doing a
Marketplace uh with a kind of verifiable
vetting process I'm actually I'm pretty
serious about it I'm I'm poking around
and what that would actually look like
it's massive undertaking but but again
having to create something that you
thought was already created uh by the
governments and the regulations and you
go well okay so we as the people have to
create it yeah I feel like
that should be the case in clothing too
like who's ever thought of putting a
label on clothing about how it was you
know it's like like we don't even think
about that but if you watch
the true cost and you know uh Olivia
Firth right like leading the charge and
you know trying to you know bring us
into reality on what's going on there
like there's a lot of work that could be
done that seems easy and for some reason
you know just it just takes a tremendous
amount of effort to like it's a sysafian
task right of pushing this bowler up the
hill yeah because it's a you know we're
again we're given a system having in it
upon birth and to now go about it you
know again we Paul Hawkins he draw down
that first book when he really spent the
time realizing if you invest in it man
it's gonna not only pay your bottom line
but it's going to pay the bottom line of
being literally regenerative along the
way so it's in your financial interest
yes to get on board with this and then
um and then is his more recent book is
just all solutions like look at all this
stuff that actually already exists right
now that we could be doing if we just
focused on it a little bit better and
that's why we need just strong bold
people business owners entrepreneurial
people that there is more and more
Capital that's being uh kind of a swell
is definitely coming but we need strong
people to continue to open up this Lane
so that we can celebrate these Solutions
I mean you know I'm not going to say
what the project is necessarily but
working on a different
television show and it's it's all based
in celebrating the solution of some of
these things that again highlight what
is going because I I think that within
all of this
even if everyone skipped the book and
went to the last third of the book right
and just went to like okay well what's
better just tell me what to do tell me
what to do right at least again that's
yeah I like how it all starts with the
each one of the sections though starts
with the DIY like make your own here's
how you make your own whatever it is and
then hey if you don't want to do that
here's five products that are pretty
good yeah like baking soda hydrogen
peroxide these things are great to clean
your vegetables and the you know yeah
it's super super easy and again we we've
become
delusioned to think that we need to buy
this special product that the tell a
vision told us to to adopt when it's
like clean your house with some white
vinegar and some water and put some
essential oil in it now it's gifting
to your life and your family and your
health yeah and and I think it's
important to also point out that you
know to your point at the outset of this
conversation that these these issues are
extremely complex and it's not about
good guys and bad guys or corporations
being evil there is a lot of really
interesting innovation in the kind of
startup space but there's also some
really valid and interesting
sustainability programs in the Fortune
500 space like Walmart is doing
interesting things I know that you have
a relationship with visa and they're you
know trying to really uh you know be a
leader in that space and I was reminded
of
this episode of Malcolm gladwell's
podcast revisionist history and I don't
know if this was
spawn con or something but he did an
interview he like spent a day at Procter
and Gamble with some scientist who
worked for you know like on tide or
whatever their laundry detergent and he
was trying to like revise our
assumptions around chemicals in cleaning
products being bad by illustrating that
this guy
had come up with a new formula for
laundry detergent but I'm sure had all
kinds of chemicals in it but the big
thing in that space is can you get
stains out can you clean the clothes in
cold water and and and through his
Innovation realized that that uh you
know his formula would reduce people's
Reliance on having to use hot water to
clean their clothes so even though it
has chemicals in it there is a an
environmental argument to support the
viability of such a product which speaks
to the complexity and I don't know if
this is true or not but like you know
that's why it's complicated like yes you
use these natural soaps and all that but
you end up having to use more hot water
because they don't [__] actually work
you know or you have to use twice as
much of whatever product because it's
just even though it's not made with all
of these things it just doesn't quite do
the job like the Fatal convenience does
yeah yeah and you pull the string on
that okay okay well what's the big deal
it's hot water well how did it become
hot like there was a power input to
create that hot water right so you're
yeah like by using hot water more hot
water with your natural soap yeah you
may in fact be unwittingly making the
environmental problem worse not better
yeah I mean I don't know what yeah it's
the amount of hot water but but but but
but that that is a good example of it's
just like let let's look at the stuff
clearly
minimizing chemical exposure
be like being transparent because
overnight if everyone was transparent
with what was actually in their products
most of these big companies who they
would have to shut that stuff down
because it's it's knowing there's Trade
Secrets and fragrances and things like
that they would have to disclose
it would be a
make Twitter files look like a little
Schoolboy you know so you know this is
again you are buying products you are
using products in your home in your car
in your clothing on your on your body on
your children what you're consuming the
water the thing and you're getting
nailed
with these chemicals all the time and it
is I can be absolutely clear that the
accumulative body burden is absolutely
affecting your body some more than
others hmm
yeah I don't I don't question you at all
on that front
um
can we talk about uh you know getting
into the complexity of things again uh
let's talk about palm oil a little bit
and
um you went deep on palm oil palm oil is
in lots of things food products and
other products and there really is no
valid uh argument to support
the continued ingestion of this product
given what it does to the planet
yeah I mean this is just you know it
goes back to the to the superfood
hunting side of things a bit when you
realize the the massive
you know
uh work that goes into
the production chain of stuff
and and out of sight out of mind for
people when when you are destroying
rainforests and habitats
um you know the symbol of that orangutan
you know I don't know if I've ever told
you the orangutan story I don't think so
the cell phone story of my orangutan
yeah stole it
maybe I'll save it but I don't know now
I feel like I need to hear that story
yeah so I mean just to button up palm
oil there's no real benefit to ingesting
it uh and it is one of those things
unless you literally are fair traded and
you have an organization that can
validate the fair trade of that said
palm oil
um that would be the only reason to use
the palm oil but uh
anyway it's a funny
um
uh funny story with our friend uh what's
his name the microbiologist uh Compton
ROM Compton ROM yeah I was gonna I was
gonna lightly chastise you for not
including ascended Health in your in
your uh syllabus of of products because
he makes amazing [__] I forgot yeah kind
of all about it in a sense his I am
beautiful oil is like I use it every day
I love it and he's got amazing
toothpaste he's got all kinds of at
least and they're like his toothpaste is
like a probiotic yeah like it's not just
not bad for you it's actually benefiting
your microbiome by using it so Compton
yeah sorry you weren't in the book
but I I big props to you right right now
ascended Health he's the one who
originally introduced us yeah do you
remember that yeah yeah that's right so
he and I were in Cambodia
and we were hunting he came with because
he was like he was like
I want to get the microbes of what
you're yeah like I'm gonna get the
microbes you'll get the fruit or the
veggie or the superfood Hunter he's the
microbe Hunter yeah yeah he literally
has traveled the world and just he'll
like talk for hours about the soil or
wherever he visited he goes get me and
he was in constantly I was in the
Philippines get me the soil no no no no
so it was interesting when you're coming
from the you know the Customs agent have
you been in contact with you know soil
I'm like oh no when you fill out the car
um no livestock yeah yeah livestock and
so so just a quick story but it's it so
we were in Cambodia looking for a bunch
of uh of superfoods
and the high level minister of
Agriculture
um there was Flooding at the time so he
kept setting up meetings but then had to
leave and and jump on a helicopter and
blah blah blah so he said hey just go to
my farm
so I'm like okay so gave it directions
we go to this farm this big gate and
kind of what seemed to be a dilapidated
Zoo
and so we're on his farm with all these
you know uh mangosteen and Moringa and
all of these things
and we're looking around like there's
literally caged animals here that were
saved from zoos from uh who knows where
so Compton
is that he goes I hear him laughing he
goes come here and he's there was a an
orangutan in a cage and number one I
hate all animals in cages I I just it
hurts me to my core but I never saw an
orangutan before so I run over there
and no sooner
did I pull up my cell phone to take a
picture of this guy this big seven foot
wingspan orangutan slapped the cell
phone out of my hand
it fell down in between the fence I I
was behind and the cage and he grabbed
it before I could grab it and he pulled
it in the cage
and so now I'm going oh my god he has my
cell phone and I see him all of the
activity in his eyes and then he was
gonna bite it and so I started making
noises I didn't know what to do
Compton's laughing his ass off the
entire time
because it happened so fast and so
anyway cut to a guy a little worker that
was there went in the cage
and he got on the back of this big male
orangutan and he was wrestling with it
and the cell phone fell
he took it and just flung it out of the
cage I got it he ran out of the cage and
there was another worker that was still
in there
and it was a little tricky for him to
get out he didn't get hurt and they
saved my cell phone and it was stolen by
an array tank that's wild man in some
kind of weird Cambodian Tiger King
situation
[Music]
I don't know how we got to that uh what
were we talking about
uh palm oil right orangutans yeah so I
mean palm oil no bueno no bueno
basically
um if there is a controversial section
in this book aside from telling people
not to eat meat you're gonna you're
gonna get some you're gonna get some
people pushing back on that probably
because this is not like a plant-based
you know Manifesto you know I know you
and I know where you stand on nutrition
um there probably will be some people
who are like totally on board and then
they get to that and they're like whoa
hold on it hold on a second we could
table that though because well normally
we've talked through that yeah normal
eating of meat you know that full of
chemicals you know that growth hormone
uh antibiotic resistant activity I
actually gave
good solutions for people who want to
eat meat in in that section so I
swallowed my pride and said hey I'm
under no delusion that everyone's gonna
go plant-based tomorrow so in that
instance you have a section where I've
vetted some companies so you can go and
have a better choice
second to that is the section on
electromagnetic radiation so let's spend
a couple minutes kind of exploring that
this is really uh the invisible elephant
the truly invisible elephant here and
and it's a it's a topic that I admit I
don't know very much about I know that
there's a certain
kind of conspiracy-minded camp that will
go to Great Lengths to make sure that
they are in a in an environment where
there is no you know EMR or whatever uh
you know Faraday tents and all the like
right uh so walk me through like a very
basic understanding of what what we're
talking about here when we're talking
about emrs emfs
Wi-Fi microwaves the differences in
these
various forms of radiation that we
expose ourselves to whether it's through
x-rays or when we're you know at the
airport going through scanning
what should we truly be concerned about
what is safe what isn't safe
[Music]
um
because I think in addition to their
just not being a lot of Education around
this there's a lack of understanding
there is a sense like yeah I don't this
probably isn't so good but like this is
the way we do things and we're just
going to have to live with it
um
and then there's you know some more kind
of radical thoughts around
5G
Etc I mean that's a topic that is
radioactive you know in its own right to
even talk about because it got co-opted
during covid and it made you know just
having any kind of reasonable
conversation about it impossible so
let me just I'm just going to throw that
radio out radioactive isotope over to
you and you tell me what's what well the
first thing is
without a doubt it's a perfect fatal
convenience right and we absolutely
need more studies
absolutely there's enough
data to show that there's a problem from
my perspective
um you know just brain Imaging of a cell
phone up to a child's head showing the
radiation going all the way through the
skull because the not only the skull
thickness but the immune system as well
um so you're really talking about
you know just I mean this is infinitely
complex but
you're talking about so ionizing
radiation so if there's a spectrum
of frequency
ionizing radiation is x-rays uh
radioactive isotopes uh uranium it will
rip your DNA apart electrons and your it
will affect you and epidemiologically it
will affect you right
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about non-ionizing
the assumption
that sets this up I think from a bad
trajectory
is assuming that as long as it's not
ionizing
it's safe because we're not seeing it
directly ripping apart the DNA
there was a lot of research that was
that and you're right it gets so wacky
when it comes to looking at this it's
just like oh my God why is it like
literally looks like
a weird lady talking about area 51. but
when you really start digging
and I believe me this was my probably my
longest chapter because I had to get
through I had to reach out to
researchers to point me into different
directions
um
uh the invisible rainbow was a good
research good book by a doctor that I
could at least go okay that's you know
even
starting the look at the history of of
just electricity so I had to think about
the consumption of information let's
start with yeah let's start with Edison
and light bulbs yeah go from there yeah
so but but it's important to go I'll
just make it short but it's important to
realize that there was data to show when
we put up the first Telegraph
that that was causing harm and migratory
patterns
and then as we continued uh UHF and
things like that in the in the in the
frequency generation and radio frequency
they saw that that there was some pretty
direct correlations to extincting uh the
red Sparrow and there was even some
anecdotal evidence to show that
um even tracking devices were messing
with migratory patterns of of of
of cats of other mammals and things like
that so
uh every time you have electricity you
have also a magnetic field
and and we are
magnetic right so we we can
easy one is the heartbeat right and so
diagnostically we know this and we use
that so we are sensitive
and just to add another aspect to it
my dad chemical sensitivity 20 years ago
I meet a doctor Dr mohsen hermanus
who changed kind of the way I looked at
nutrition came from sixth generation
herb farmers and then he was a
mathematician as well as a master in in
Understanding Nutrition on a cellular
level
he was the first but he gave me the term
fatal convenience he was the first
person 25 years ago to say
electrically our DNA
is sending signals through the RNA right
and chemically too but electrically
those things are happening and so the
instructions of
of the proteins going to replace maybe
cenets and cells are a part of the
process always millions and millions and
billions of times a day
and he started pointing 25 years ago he
started pointing me to research to go
this is the electric field of a cell
phone is affecting that DNA and now
I was looking at
many studies showing that the guy Lomas
where you'd have a cell phone up to your
head was creating these tumor like not
even like but these tumors
so so then multiple studies showing that
so you're like okay well let's study it
some more instead of blowing it off so
these kinds of things started to to show
up now the other areas which was weirdly
similar to a chemical exposure of a
phthalate or something that it would
show radical oxygen species like free
radicals as a like the the mechanism of
cellular uh metabolism was being
thwarted and stressed and and then you
would see things that really scared me
that I didn't know
and there was one study that showed that
this uh protein albumin that is not
supposed to be in the brain uh
uh showed that by the exposure of a cell
phone frequency
opened up the blood brain barrier to
allow that albumin to show up in the
brain which had a Cascade of problems in
the brain so I so similar to the
exposure I saw stress I saw a free
radical oxygen species I saw stress of
the immune system
and these things and then obviously the
blood brain barrier which is a really
bad scenario to open up and those came
back in many studies and my fact
Checkers checked them again and
and I was like oh my God this is like a
chemical exposure and
the other part of it was lowering sperm
counts
so this exposure of a cell phone and
then you're going wow the proximity is a
is an issue here so the proximity of
this device in your head on your laps in
your pockets and the workout Mama who's
putting the cell phone in her sports bra
these are problems and these are
proximal problems and again this was
dude this was a rabbit hole right and I
had to conclude I had to stop some of
this stuff because I couldn't find
enough information but the history
started me on this path
the telecommute I'll say it here I
believe that the Telecommunications
business
knows about this stuff they know about
these studies
something interesting happened I I
didn't really talk about it in the book
but in 1993
the EPA which I think was right in terms
of it was their responsibility to study
the electric the electromagnetic fields
of cell towers and cell phones
that they had their guy study this and
found
many of the things that I explained to
you and said okay
you guys hired me I we need to tell the
consumer
and overnight it was shifted to the FCC
and the epa's funding dried up so now
what year was that how long ago was that
94. and there's documentation on this
yeah a red countless articles I even
read an old facts that was this guy's
report
so then so now the FCC holds it so now
the FCC is 20 years behind the
technology
and their only basically saying things
are safe based on thermal
reaction if it burns you
then it's not safe they're not taking
into the account the frequency waves the
one two three G four G five G all of
these things and the magnetic fields
that come with all of this stuff they're
not including that they don't even
mention any of it when it was showing up
in the initial study so yeah man this is
crazy
that all of this stuff but the thing
that kept coming up over and over again
is without a doubt there's real data to
show that a child's immune system is
compromised it is affected and you are
stressed out you are stressed out I'm as
stressed out on a on a molecular level
not from what you're looking at on the
device but from the device itself yeah
yeah I I mean do you have a sense of of
ongoing research and studies that are
occurring now around this are people
like I I guess what I'm saying is or my
thought is
certainly we should be studying this
this is ubiquitous we all use these
things uh you know I know what it's like
I used to hold the thing to my ear and
if you're on a long phone call like not
only does it start to get hot there like
it doesn't feel like I start to get a
headache like I'm like that I know that
that's not right you know I don't know
what's going on but it you know I don't
do that anymore right but I use
Bluetooth and I use Wi-Fi and you know
we run our studio with tons of
electronic equipment and you know
there's all kinds of
waves and frequencies pinging around
constantly and we just this is part of
what it is to be a modern human being in
the developed world and you know look I
listened to the radio when I was I was a
kid and I had a TV like you did with the
with the antenna and that's coming
through the air and I'm okay so is there
really anything to worry about here and
you know if you want to talk about 5G
then you might as well put your tin foil
hat on and go talk to David Ike and and
you guys can chat about the lizard
people right like you can't it's right
but we have to be able to we have to be
able to like have a rational
evidence-based
science-backed conversation about this
thing that is in the hands of billions
of people all over the world 100 and it
you know unfortunately through all of
that it got co-opted into all these
other side conversations about I I just
wanted to bring it down to
what is it doing and there's multiple
studies showing that it's causing an
immune response the blood-brain barrier
freaked me out uh the the if the
lower immune system that's not kind of
up to par yet as a child is is is
they're much more affected uh it is
causing stress and so uh it definitely
needs more studies and it definitely
needs the attention that it deserves and
the FCC has to up update their their
understanding not even their
understanding but their their their
health measures right I mean the FCC
sorry to step on your words but the FCC
is it's it's its mandate is to regulate
the communications industry it's not met
it's not set up to look out for the you
know the health considerations of of you
know what these communications companies
are doing that's that's the you know the
Department of Health and the
Environmental Protection there are other
organizations that it sounds like based
on what you said were divested of their
authority to to kind of police and
regulate that is that the case yeah it's
weird I mean I don't know what really
happened but I just know that that that
switch happened that the EPA definitely
was studying telecommunications uh
kind of through the the funding I think
of the Telecommunications
companies and then when the researcher
forget his name off the top of my head
Carlos something
um and and then he came out with hey man
this is what I found and he was wanting
to share it and then let's tell
everybody and you know again I know this
sounds weird but if I wasn't reading it
I'd be like
what the hell like again what the hell
shows up in a lot of these things in the
book like what the hell is the pfos
doing on my child's diaper and my like
why is elastane in my clothes that's
causing me stress so so this one was a
massive one I I I'm just I'm worried
because obviously
one two three four G 5G they're all here
it doesn't it's just because we're
switching to 5G and it's a little
different Milli millimeter wave it
doesn't travel as far so they have to
put up more Towers more Towers yeah and
that means just more electrical
pollution uh and then on top of it you
know about 40 to 50 000 satellites uh
these micro satellites that they want to
blanket the Earth so that we can SM
quote unquote use this facetiously
smartify the world
um hey man like let's let's study this I
I don't want
the electrical pollution of things that
I'm seeing strong indicators that we at
least let's freaking study it like so
again let's have a com I'm not the
expert in it I don't know but I've read
a huge amount that says
this is not
clean there's there's some dangers
present here there's this uh Swedish
study that you talk about in the book uh
that describes this thing they call the
the uh the microwave syndrome uh in
which in this study there was a couple
living in an apartment that began to
suffer from a long list of symptoms like
fatigue and they couldn't sleep
nosebleeds tinnitus skin problems
dizziness concentration issues heart
palpitations all of which decreased or
disappeared within a day after they
moved to another home with significantly
lower radiation all the conditions they
suffered under exposure to 5G radio
waves are identical to those first
described more than 50 years ago by
people who received whole body microwave
radiation now is that a study if it's a
couple like it's almost anecdotal like I
don't know that you can really extract
extract from that anything all that
meaningful from a scientific perspective
but from an anecdotal perspective like
okay well
that's sort of concerning yeah yeah and
again you know I I gave those examples
simply because
it's happening to many people similar to
my father like two great Tech Wellness
companies one's literally called Tech
Wellness another company of the UK is
called conscious spaces both of those
women who started those companies were
chemical or were were Electro sensitive
so they started minimizing uh companies
now we're not talking about the famous
sticker to put on you we're talking
about blocking devices we're talking
about plugging back in turning off Wi-Fi
turning off at night and that's the
thing if people like one of the minimal
things that you can do is turn off your
Wi-Fi at night right that's a stress
that you don't need and you're not using
so uh and because we go on to to talk
about the multiple mice studies that
start to show up uh around the
blood-brain barrier or the immune
response and things like that so yeah
there's a anecdotal there's tons yeah
similar to father it's a trip man did
you think when you were putting this
book together like maybe I should just
leave the whole 5G thing out of it for
for sure yeah yeah but it's it's there's
too much compelling
information to just leave it you know
it's like it's it's
the 5G side of it is we are think about
the theme Here
we all of these fatal conveniences that
we're talking about they haven't done
the proper studies to deem them safe
and there's it's the same Playbook
they haven't proven
that 1G 2G 3G 4G 5G are completely safe
so I'm just raising my hand going hey
man before we're blasting us all the
time 24 7 and we don't have a choice
let's dig into it
tell me that it's safe not just you know
of course it's safe and uh you know no
we need
double bind control trials to show me to
prove that
please disprove the the research studies
that that I read please disprove them
show me like we need this kind of action
and actionable things and the the
awareness that I hope everyone starts to
understand is there are things that are
going on in this world that
unfortunately have greater uh
motivations than the the health of us
and our environment and we need to you
know hold more accountability for some
of these people so that we can you know
again we have numbers on our side so
let's turn on that common sense and just
ask questions man like let's ask for
these things for Change and ask these
questions so that we can like go okay
prove to me they're safe
and I'm good so I in the meantime I use
blocking safe sleeve on it I use these
other companies I plug back in by the
way plugging in it's a lot faster
and yeah just ethernet it and you do
you're like oh here are some cases you
can use and hear some other thing you
know you can go all the way to the
extreme using the Faraday Temple you
know to like really block it out and go
full Ben Greenfield on the whole thing
um but there are very simple fixes that
that you know are not that inconvenient
um which is the case for all the
categories throughout the book so again
in the appendices all sorts of
suggestions products that you vetted Etc
but I think you know to kind of close
this out and and you know bring this to
some level of finality for today
there is a sense that I have that one
could read this and and be like
overwhelmed like okay well like okay you
don't have you only have to change one
thing which is basically everything like
every single product in your house every
appliance that you have the paint on
your walls and the cart you got to strip
out the carpets and throw your mattress
out and like get rid of all your clothes
like it's a lot dude right so it's
somebody's embarking on this journey and
they're like okay well I gotta start
somewhere like what are the what are the
you know the things that are the most
important to address first may be paired
with the easiest changes or most
convenient changes to make to you know
launch somebody on their own you know
version of your journey yeah great
question rich I mean I I think of it in
this way go in to out so the
vulnerability of opening your mouth and
consuming a liquid or water or food
start there because that that is there's
plenty so probably the easiest one is
filter your water
because we know that that's
affecting
98 of many parts of the country in pfos
and microplastics so filter water and RO
system distillation Ro super easy Ro is
reversal reverse osmosis and again like
I've said many times before add some
unrefined salt
um and also not all Himalayan salt is
created equal not all salt is it can be
microplastics and that stuff too but so
go to places like real Salt there's a
mine in Utah or uh the original
Himalayan salt it's got a long great
track record things like that so add the
uh stuff back in and then you know what
else are you consuming so looking at
your food containers wrapping your food
hot
and rat hot food wrapped in plastic is a
perfect prescription for uh
uh phthalates pfos uh
microplastics estrogens all of that
stuff so
minimize that right and then minimize
Ultra processed food because everything
from uh heavy metals and pfos and and
other bisphenols are showing up also in
that so food is a good water beverage
food and then longer things that you're
putting on your body so what I mean by
that is lotions that are staying on your
body these things you should be looking
for natural
products many of which I've vetted in
there that are clean and healthy for
your skin and doesn't disrupt that
precious microbiome and then things like
shampoos and conditioners you're they're
not
staying on the largest portions of your
body as much but then again just think
of it keep going out improve your
bathroom
situation uh have this great company
that I like called bite bite toothpaste
yeah so they sent me some of their
products they're correct they're like
tablets for brushing your teeth right so
you throw a tablet in you bite down you
just brush normally and then it's all
compostable uh refillable glass jars
you're eliminating that the the harsh
chemicals then stabilizers and uh uh
things in your toothpaste because that's
a chemical chemical soup so again that's
going in your mouth dental floss that
that was a big one too
so that slippery little sliding guess
what that is
pfas man don't put that in your mouth
[__] up that's crazy so you know what
I do is I get a bamboo charcoal dental
floss I just wet it and it's basically
as good so just wet it first boom you
don't have to put pfos in your mouth
ever again I'm disappointed that you
don't make your own dental floss though
weaving it in the back 40. sorry Rich
I'm gonna I'm running late to the
podcast
I got this yucco yucca plant would be
good to actually pull that apart that
would actually work I'm gonna do a real
uh uh on Instagram just for you all
right good
um and then you know work your way out
work your way out to your clothing and
be more responsible like that work your
way out to your your home what kind of
cleaning products things like that and
just keep uh you know moving forward you
don't have to be perfect but you're just
moving forward to clean up your
environment so that you can have the
best life ever right on man
um I love you buddy you did a great job
with this book it's it's a real Act of
of public service
and uh
I think it's gonna do really well man
can't wait for it to be out in the world
and and start impacting people so we can
change the world thanks dude yeah it's a
it's like a guide I think that I hope
that people can just open it up and and
learn a little something every day and
I've started applying it so
it's a big lift for sure yeah and
anything else up on the horizon that
you're you want to talk about
yeah I've got a lot of [__] going on we
could we could spend five more hours
talking about all the projects you got
your yeah Muddy Paws in yeah I mean you
know down to earth
you know season three it doesn't look
like it's gonna happen
um
uh there's some challenges with many
different things but
I'm not gonna divulge it but I hinted at
it I am working on some really cool
other television projects that are I'm
stoked about and um again all solution
based moving forward still working to
build out my house
um yeah and still in the year working on
getting the uh in the sustainable
housing project uh up on its feet yeah
and you know I got a new partner with
barookas with Steve fabos and it cleaned
up a lot of things so I'm I'm so excited
for that business and that nut to get
out putting my formulator hat back on so
I'm formulating some stuff with with the
nut and other superfoods and stuff so
that I'm stoked about and then you know
working in the clean energy space with
my crazy friends uh in the science
community and
um clean energy Tech so that's some of
the stuff that people don't know much
about because it's not public but we're
working with governments around the
world and
uh New Zealand Australia Mexico uh and
and and here in the states too of
creating clean power and that's a whole
nother thing but yeah it just helps to
you know you know we're here and so I
just want to give it my best right on
man yeah well maybe you can come back
and we can do a whole clean energy
conversation in the meantime barucha's
you know this is we didn't even mention
baruchas until the very end here but
um
is it available Nationwide can people
overseas get it if people want to you
gotta check out veruca's nut oh man go
listen to our other podcast about it but
a delicious super nutritious
superfood uh nut product that is your
company yeah it's the greatest it's the
greatest not ever I mean it literally
checks all the boxes uh
and meaning that it's we had a which
maybe you didn't know we had a third
party Swiss company do an audit of our
process of how we collect and not how we
work with the nut how we deliver the nut
and the whole process of fair trade and
planting trees and supporting the biome
and the sahadu and we we
rated higher than any company that
they've ever tested so we're
a carbon sink by us literally just being
in business today and we're still
improving on that process so yeah people
can get the the product Nationwide I
really hope that the UK and other places
open up soon
um but it's it's delicious it's my
passion it kind of represents the
superfood side of me because it gets to
support the people there help a biome
that's being hurt with deforestation and
and the customers get to not only have
the micronutrients of a wild food
but they get to enjoy it as well and all
your guests now will be yeah you're
gonna you gotta keep us stocked over
here I will I will happily Pawn them off
on every guest that walks in here
um so I assume it's in I I know it's in
a variety of supermarkets here but
should people try to buy it online or
should they look for it in their like
Natural Foods Market or well you can
certainly help us out by asking for your
local grocer to carry it uh and then
they'll the you know we're gonna do some
bigger campaigns but you can get it
online and most people don't know we
have an amazing butter and we have the
chocolate covered because early in the
early days we would be stocked up and
then we'd lose we didn't have the
mechanism sorted out so we would be
start and stop so now we're guns blazing
for lucas.com verucas.com all right in
the meantime pick up fatal conveniences
and uh just sit quietly at home and
await Darren's uh next appearance on the
podcast whenever that might be all right
like I said I love you buddy and uh I'm
here to support you love you thank you
brother cheers peace plants